the Dutch royal family have formally
apologized for slavery they've
commissioned a committee of historians
to look into the history the French have
commissioned really serious Research
into what to do with their colonial
items Germany has paid reparations you
know they're just much more on it and
even America they there's serious
conversations about reparations you know
but in Britain our answer is no we have
legislation Banning the return of items
right and you saw it at the coronation
the gap between what the commonwealth
countries wanted to talk about
reparations return of their Loot and our
total refusal to go into well I mean
King Charles did give a bit of ground in
he he's finally well the queen consult
didn't wear the Coen all yeah that was a
kind of political Dodge also he said he
approves of the research he the Royal
archives being opened up to research
yeah but we're talking about one PhD
researcher who might report by 2026
compared to what the Dutch royal family
are doing it's ridiculously small and
compared to how much of an issue it is
even within the Commonwealth the
Commonwealth I mean it's we struggle to
say what it's for but one thing they
really do want to talk about is
reparations and it's the one thing we
don't want to talk
about um do you think it's helpful to
talk about decolonizing the
curriculum just that particular word do
you think that's quite a divisive word
yeah I think it's divisive I think it
puts people's backs up also I think
ultimately it's impossible CU like if
you're going to
decolonize this room first of all we
wouldn't be here you know you got to
undo some profound things you know the
wealth that slavery produced is baked
into Britain it's like trying to take
you know the egg out of a baked cake you
can't compensate for slavery cuz you
You' be talking about trillions some and
people do try to calculate the amount of
money and we're talking trillions and
trillions of pounds I thought that was
what was very interesting actually in
this book is that you when you're
talking about the wealth and you talk
about how Empire shaped towns and cities
and Countryside you you you really kind
try and draw that out in places around
the country so that children actually
look up and look at these buildings and
think about the wealth and how these
buildings came to be there um why was
that important to include that I think
with kids you've got to related to their
lives and probably with adults too and
uh that's one of the easiest ways I mean
so much so many everyday items like
nutmeg um HP Source wer Source all
arguably come from Empire which people
wouldn't think about I mean yeah I mean
I'm I'm always discovering things I
discovered the other day that my English
course I did English at University
English was taught as an academic
subject in India before it was taught in
Britain and actually it was imported
into Britain a lot of the teaching
materials used in India were used here
that's amazing the idea that my English
courses also had a colonial element to
it it's but I'm always discovering I
discovered things whilst researching
stuff for this book you know which I had
thought about London Zoo I'd never
thought about how that had Colonial
Origins you know I didn't know what
Raffles was involved in creating it and
um things keep coming up all the
time um one of the most important parts
of the book um which is actually a
really important part of understanding
Britain and Multicultural Britain is the
explanation of the 1948 nationality act
which was like kind of such a turning
point moment for me uh and probably you
too when I realized that actually there
was a piece of legislation that meant
that our moms and dads when they came
over were British citizens uh and that
that they were already British because
of because of Empire and not all of them
not all of them but until the
legislation was of course but but
initially until until they kind of
fundamentally the people on the Wind
Rush the wind Rush exactly up until 1962
and then it it began to be watered down
um and so that when people say go home
actually you know they were British
where would they go home too is that is
that why you kind of make a big point of
it in the book you're trying to show
children this kind of longer history
yeah and I think it's the most important
lesson because the wind everyone seems
to have forgotten about the Windrush
Scandal but our government deported
British citizens to countries they
didn't even know you know because the
level of knowledge about Empire was so
poor amongst civil servants that's what
that's the real world consequence of not
knowing this history you know and that
was one of the things that the wind Rush
inquiry picked up on that we need to
teach people the basic fact that black
people in in the 1950s and 40s came as
citizen cens and I still think that's
really poorly understood and I think
it's partly a consequence of the media
narrative endless idea that brown people
are Interlopers and don't really belong
and it's amazing that that narrative
persists when we have a British Asian
prime minister British Asian head head
of the S SMP it still persists doesn't
it and it's been really Bleak that the
government are watering down what
they're going to do about wind rush you
know step by step they did say they were
going to take on all the all the
recommendations of the report and now
they're not and it's shocking we should
have been more angry about it I think
people are angry for like a month and
then everyone's just forgotten about it
and but that's the direct consequence of
not knowing your history and the same
was in the Steven Lawrence report as
well wasn't it yeah it comes up
regularly it's like happens every 10
years everyone has a dark eye of the
Soul Britain feels really bad about its
own racism for about two weeks and then
we go back to the normal narrative which
which is actually we are Beyond racism
because we beat the evil racist Nazis we
abolished slavery and now the narratives
we have a British Asian prime minister
therefore racism doesn't exist has never
existed it's just not
true what I think is really uh unusual
about your book is you give practical
advice to Children about who face racism
um or how to challenge Silence about
learning about Empire but also really
importantly how to be an ally that you
you're giving lots of different types of
kids of
vocabulary why you why did you do that I
think uh I know I I know from personal
experience that it can feel very lonly
you know having this knowledge and a lot
of people not having it it can kind of
make you feel isolated and uh I just
didn't want kids to read all this
information about EMP Empire and then
not know what to do with it and I think
there are constructive ways to talk
about this stuff I mean it's too uh
competitive the way we talk about Empire
I think you can have a a debate within a
school about whether Sir Richard Drax
should pay reparations to the
descendants of the slaves that enriched
him and made him one of the richest MPS
in Parliament you can have a a debate
about that without it being toxic you
know and you can learn a lot of things
and you can you can be on both sides I
can see both sides of that argument um I
so I think think kids are much more
flexible than we give them credit
for you say build a statue um that
you're not that into tearing down
statues what would be your
statue um I mainly not into tear down
statues because um I feel like they're
Street Furniture we already think about
them in recent years right um I put one
on for Dean Muhammad the first Indian
who ever wrote a book in English the
first Indian to open actually the first
person to open a Curry House in Britain
and who ended up being a kind of massage
therapist for the king in Brighton um
incredible life and kind of Forgotten
Mar an Irish woman didn't you married an
Irish woman yeah I been to be honest my
whole Adventure into Empire started with
him CU I wanted I thought oh you know
what I'll write a novel about this
amazing weird guy and um I thought I
better research what it was like to come
from India and what it was like under
the East India Company and cuz he came
over with the East India
Company uh manager of sorts and I
started researching and that led to
Empire land so here we are oh I didn't
realize that well down to D Muhammad um
I've just been thinking a lot about
change um and because people talk about
apologies they talk about reparations
you mentioned some European countries
that are doing it considering it but
could change also be the next generation
and that they deal with this this
subject that in In Our Lifetime has
become so kind of as you say toxic they
just deal with it perhaps in a more
adult way yeah I think there's too much
focus on oh we got to change the
curriculum um the curriculum doesn't
matter that much because academies don't
have to teach it private schools don't
have to teach it um and as we know Wales
and Scotland have different curriculums
and also I do feel like kids are getting
their knowledge from other sources like
uh podast I mean the Empire podcast is
incredible you've been you've both been
on it yeah and uh rest of his history I
mean did an amazing couple of episodes
on Christopher Columbus there's
Instagram accounts like the history
Corridor run by a history teacher black
and brown history account on his and you
got I joined Tik Tok and yesterday and
uh I think your publisher told you to do
that I did and I've got only a thousand
views of one video and
probably 200 racist messages so the the
view to racist abuse ratios is
incredible but kids are getting their
knowledge from all sorts of different
sources and yeah the change is happening
so you know people on the far right can
attempt to take it on but I think it's
having no effect on the
young why is it at this particular
moment in time so if you if we think
about the British Empire really drawing
to an end from beginning with 1947 when
they withdrew from India why is it now
20 in our the 2023 that the Empire is so
incendiary why now I think about this a
lot it's like it's bizarre isn't it
because Empire ended a while ago why is
it now one of the biggest topics in the
world partly I think it's like I said
earlier the British destroyed the
evidence and historians are only just
discovering some of it the Mao case is a
classic example um and even now you
can't get Lord M batton's papers right
you can't read them and he was such an
important figure for Indian independence
but on top of that I think the first
postcolonial generation I'm thinking
here of people like our parents who
immigrated but also the people running
India and and Nigeria and so on they
were so focused on building themselves
like building India and dealing with
frankly with all the destruction caused
by the British they didn't have energy
to go over the history and I feel like
new generations have the time and
luxury and to sit down and actually
think about it but maybe they feel more
secure to do that as well like their
place here absolutely and it's an
amazing thing I didn't think Britain
would be as confident about its
multiculturalism as it's become I don't
think and and that's actually a really
important thing to say that in our
lifetime so much has changed I mean when
we were kids to think that you and I
would be sitting here talking like this
we wouldn't have imagined it would we no
I know I went back to my Cambridge
College to talk about Empire and it was
amazing that their English course has
been
decolonized but it also really pissed me
off cuz it's like it's off air why did
we not have any of that you know it took
me so long and uh but yeah I mean it's
all different now isn't it so if things
have changed in our
lifetime maybe in our lifetime we will
also see a time where actually we are
more comfortable about talking about
Empire and our past it's got to happen I
mean in a fundamental way truth prevails
you
cannot you can't suppress the truth man
it's going to come out you can fight it
you can try to uh call these people
people like us woke culture Warriors and
whatever you cannot argue with the facts
you cannot argue with the consensus
amongst Imperial historians that can
change but you need a lot of evidence
and so I think it's inevitable I just
wonder when you were that little kid in
in wolver Hampton um growing up in your
Punjabi family
what would having had a book like this
in your household have done for you I
think it would have given me a better
sense of place in in Britain it would
have made me help me understand the
racism that was all Fading in wolver
Hampton um but he would have explained
the seik psychology because the seik uh
identity as a martial race which is one
we've really gone for and embraced was
created by the British the SE Community
arguably grew to large numbers in the
19th century because the British adopted
us as a a loyal race to fight for them
after we took their side generally after
1857 right and so so much about British
sixs can be explained by British Empire
and I don't think British seeks
necessarily understand that and I
certainly didn't know it no one's ever
explained it to me until I I found it
said by historians in quite obscure
books